normally the summer heat slows down
migrant surges at our southern border
but not now
last week alone over 20 thousand illegal
immigrants were apprehended in the rio
grande valley sector
just weeks after we hit the million
migrant milestone last month
this weekend one woman crossing the
border stopped to talk to reporters
saying quote
thanks to president biden for the
opportunity to come here now
when there is an open southern border
the entire country is put at risk
which is why south dakota governor
christie gnomes sent national guard
troops
to help do what the biden administration
won't which is secure our country
she joins me now for an exclusive
interview from the southern border in
mcallen texas
governor gnome welcome aboard you know
last time i saw you it was at cpac in a
hallway
everything was just so fast moving along
but i i talked to you at that point
because i was in speaking with the
participants at cpac people were asking
who is your dream team
for 2024 and of course president trump
we know
is uh is a favorite of all of us your
name also came up
and i don't i've been a big admirer of
yours i
and yet was i was surprised to hear that
but b
you've been in the news you're now at
the border um
uh can you can you tell us what your
what you think your own impact is as the
governor of south dakota certainly now
with your
national guard troops on the border uh
and does this uh
a national message that you want to send
to the american people
well for us when governor abbott and
governor ducey asked for help securing
the border we recognized it immediately
as a national security issue
something the federal government should
be doing but was neglecting to
and for us in south dakota that impacts
us also the drugs that come across this
border
end up in south dakota filter a lot
through my indian reservations and end
up throughout the midwest and then we
also have a huge
human trafficking issue in this country
that this open border is facilitating so
for us
we had many reasons to respond to
governor abbott's request for help
and the reason i set my national guard
is because this is
exactly what they do with excellence
that's one of the great things that was
good to hear on the ground here today
from border patrol
was how grateful they were that i sent
national guard they they perform
missions like this
it's clearly defined they know their
training level when they get here they
can work as a team
and a unit they complete the task and
then when it's completed
south dakota's known for doing it with
excellence so our folks are in
observation posts they're watching and
identifying those that are crossing and
then notifying border patrol to come and
pick them up but you said it tammy
twenty thousand
last week just in this zone area which
is
unbelievable behind me we have children
right now
crossing the border with family units
which will just be
you know located with an ngo and then
dispersed and
dislocated all over the country governor
it's it's a human catastrophe
and the things that make it worse uh you
know we see horrible things
what we don't see is is what is a tragic
uh the children who didn't make it uh
the women
who are destroyed in the process and
then used through sex trafficking
these things the the drugs that we don't
see
moving across the border as you've noted
affect every state
of this union you came under fire you've
come under fire by both the left and the
right which means
perhaps you're doing something right uh
the left was upset that you sent the
national guard
i don't know why they wouldn't want more
security at the border and of course
the right considers you um not
strong enough on certain issues uh what
do you view your role as governor in
this case
and uh is this something that you worry
about and
and what what do you think governors can
do as you're doing
when it comes to having an impact at the
national level
well i mean we just need to do our job i
think what we saw in 2020 was a lot of
governors trying to be political and not
do their job
so that's what i'm focused on and this
issue down here
is a national security issue it's
impacting my people in south dakota i
have
the excellent group of individuals that
can respond
in in a way that can define the mission
and complete it with excellence
that's exactly what we did and they're
here an important part of the team in
fact texas has indicated that they want
more resources more commitment
the need is here and it's only expected
to become even greater
and right here all of these coyotes that
are moving these individuals across
the border right now they they are
making money off these people they're
making money off these children they
know if they have a child
a six and under that they will not be
detained and that they'll be turned over
to an
ngo and then released into the rest of
the country so it's they're making money
off of people
and yeah and and law doesn't mean
anything in the biden administration but
that's why
south dakota is responding and we'll do
what we can yes the
the disruption is horrible so you
wouldn't say no if someone wanted your
expertise in washington in summer
i think i'm very happy in south dakota
you know that's
i'm doing my job i ran for governor
to be in south dakota so that's my focus
it's a beautiful state
it's a beautiful state you're doing a
great job all right governor
governor gnome thank you very much i
think there might be more more time to
ask that question again in the future
thank you ma'am
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else